okay so in this video we're going to
discuss ferns and some of the basic
features of them so let's go ahead and
get started so before we get into ferns
I just want to take a moment to discuss
plants in general and how they alternate
between diploid generations and haploid
generations so the diploid generation of
a plant is known as the sporophyte and
the haploid generation of a plant is
known as the comida fight well let's
start right here in area one of the
diagram with a zygote you should know
that a zygote is diploid so as I go
we'll be created from egg and sperm and
if a zygote is diploid zygote marks the
beginning of the diploid stage which we
call the sporophyte now follow the arrow
in this diagram the zygote will be
created and then we'll divide by mitosis
and when the zygote divides by mitosis
it will grow into what we call the
sporophyte so the sporophyte has the
word Spore in it so the sporophyte makes
spores follow the arrow the sporophyte
make spores through the process of
meiosis and so when when meiosis creates
cells you should know that those cells
will be haploid so the sporophyte made
haploid spores and often those spores
are just released into the air and so
the one when the spores are released
into the air some of the spores when
they land will grow into the female
gametophyte other spores when they land
will grow into the male gametophyte
so some spores become the female
gametophyte and in the word gametophyte
you should be able to see the word
gamete so the female gametophyte will
create the female gamete which you
should know is the egg and some of the
other spores when they land on the
ground will grow into the male
gametophyte again in the word
gametophyte you can see the word for
gamete so the male gametophyte creates
the male gamete which you should know is
sperm so as we near the end of the cycle
Aegon sperms
dolls are released by the gametophyte
the female gametophyte creates the egg
and the male computer fight creates the
sperm and that kind of brings us back to
the beginning of this cycle sperm and
egg will create a diploid zygote and the
process will repeat itself I hope you'll
see this pattern as we go through the
fern lifecycle near the end of the video
ok so now I want to get into the second
group of plants that we are learning in
this unit the seedless and vascular
plants and so the evolutionary
advancement in these notes today that we
are really focusing on is the
evolutionary advancement of a vascular
system in my previous video when we
talked about group 1 the seedless and
the nonvascular plants and we really
focused on mosses mosses are seedless so
our today's plans ferns the difference
is that mosses do not have a vascular
system but today we're learning about
plants that do and so the advancement of
a vascular system allows these plants to
grow taller and allows the transport
nutrients to greater heights there's now
a way for water to be delivered from the
roots to greater heights there's now a
way for glucose that is created through
photosynthesis and the leaves to be
transported downward to the roots and so
when you look at the mosses which are
non vascular no wonder why the mosses
are growing so small to the ground and
they don't grow very tall mosses are non
vascular they don't have a way to
transport nutrients great distances but
ferns which are going to be
representative of the plants we talked
about today can be much taller this is
because of their vascular system so
another thing to mention is that the
plant today plants today the seedless
and the vascular plants they reproduce
in moist environment they have sperm
cells that have to swim through water so
even though these plants live on land
they have swimming sperm cells that will
swim through rain water and so a few
things about the structure of ferns so
ferns have the a very primitive root
system known as rhizoids and again they
anchor into the soil they absorb
nutrients the leaves of a ferns are what
we are what we call a friend and fronds
have little structures on the underside
of them that are going to eventually
really spores into the air we'll talk
more about them in just a moment if we
look at this picture right here here's a
fiddle now the reason I have a picture
of a fiddle in the middle of a plant
video look at the very top the head of
the fiddle that the head of the fiddle
is curved and curled piece of wood and
so the reason I'm showing this picture
is because this right here is a fiddle
head and it's kind of how it gets its
name this is the frond curled up so
ferns when their fronds are curled up we
call it a fiddle head
here's another picture of some
fiddleheads and in this picture here's
some fiddleheads that are uncurling and
they uncurl into the leaves of a fern
which we call a frond now on the back
side of the fern we see these little
spots these little patches we're going
to learn more about these patches in a
few moments but these structures produce
spores that will eventually be released
into the air and here's another close-up
here's a better close-up of those spore
producing structures on the backside of
a friend so a couple categories before
we go into the lifecycle I want to
mention categories of seedless vascular
plants club mosses even though they have
the word moss in them they're not true
losses they were Mis named you know
early in our classification it turns out
club mosses were thought to be mosses
but hey they're not they have a vascular
system there are the horsetails
but really the main topic we're going to
focus on today in this video are the
ferns so we're going to use ferns to
represent the seedless vascular plant
okay so let's go ahead and look at the
lifecycle of a fern well here's a
picture of some ferns growing outside of
a
an apartment complex and anytime you see
ferns what you're looking at is the
sporophyte stage you're looking at the
diploid stage of ferns anytime you come
across them the sporophyte stages the
diploid stage so the sporophyte stage is
the dominant stage it's the stage in
which ferns are most noticeable it's the
stage in which firms spend the majority
of their existence so anytime you come
across ferns you're looking at the
sporophyte stage the diploid stage and
so fronds again the leaves of a fern are
called Franz Franz house these
structures on them called sore I now who
here is the picture you saw a few
moments ago couple fiddleheads uncurling
into a friend
and once they uncurl here's a friend
that you can see all these are those
spots all these little patches each
patch is what we call a soros SOR u.s.
soros all of them collectively are
called Sorai
so again here's that picture you saw a
moment ago each individual source
contains little structures that produce
spores and that's what sporangia are
sporangia are the spore producing
structures that are found within each
Saurus so a Saurus is a cluster of spore
producing structures it's a cluster of
sporangia and that's what sporangia do
sporangia make spores they make spores
through the process of meiosis
so spores must be haploid and once the
sporangia
create the spores the spores are simply
released into the air eventually the
spores will land on the ground and they
will grow into the next stage in the
life of a fern the haploid stage called
the gametophyte so once a spore lands on
the ground it grows into the haploid
stage known as the Commuter fight now in
this picture there's a small
heart-shaped
leaf in the middle of this picture right
here this is the the gametophyte stage
now in ferns the gametophyte stage is
called the pro thalis a heart-shaped
leafy structure no bigger than then then
your fingernail so the the pro thalis is
fairly small it's very easy not to see
just because it's again only about the
size of a fingernail so here's a drawing
of a ferns gametophyte of a ferns pro
thalis and there's a few structures i
want to show you that exist so it's got
the root structures called the rhizoids
it also has what are called archegonia
these are the female structures the
archegonia another reason it's called
the female structure is because the
archegonia produces egg cells well if
you notice there's all those there's
those five or so circular structures at
the bottom these are the male structures
the male structures are called the
antheridia and so the reason they're
male structures the reason the male
structures is because they produce sperm
so the archegonium is the female
structure that produces eggs and the n3
dium is the male structure that produces
sperm so when you have two gametophyte
next to one another like you see here or
two Pro phalluses next to each other
like you see right here eventually sperm
will swim from the male structure sperm
will swim from the male and 3d 'm to the
female archegonium where eventually
fertilization will take place to make a
zygote now in order for the sperm to
swim there has to be rain water on the
ground which will go through in just a
moment but once the sperm and the egg
four fuse together in fertilization
occurs a zygote is created and the
zygote is the beginning of the diploid
stage so the cycle simply repeats itself
let's look at this in a little more
detail so let's look at this process in
a little more detail so here we have
here we have a fern and you can see the
fronds standing up so spores are
released from the sorai on the backside
of the front so again here is our adult
sporophyte
in the animation you see it's releasing
a bunch of black dots those black dots
are representing of spores so their
spores are just released into the air
well let's just follow one spore as it
lands on the ground well what's going to
happen to this one spore now again
spores are haploid so the spore
represents the beginning of the haploid
stage called the gametophyte
so that spore is going to grow into that
heart-shaped structure called the pro
phallus now again in reality of
over-exaggerated the size right here in
reality that you know it's about the
size of a fingernail so it's fairly
small but this heart-shaped structure
called the pro thalis this is the ferns
gametophyte stage it's haploid stage and
again let's not forget there are male
structures on it to produce sperm called
n3 dia and there are female structures
on it to produce eggs called the
archegonia well let's just focus on the
male and 3d right now because sperm
cells are going to swim from the male
antheridia to the female archegonia now
in order for sperm cells to swim there
needs to be something for them to swim
through so whenever it rains here EODs
it's raining in my animation so once
there's once it's rained and there's
some water on the ground now watch what
happens
sperm cells can swim from the male and
3d well let's go follow those sperm
cells so the sperm cells can swim from
the male n3 dia and here's just one
sperm so finding a female archegonium
and so when sperm and egg come together
again that's going to create a zygote so
a zygote will be created in the process
of fertilization and a zygote you should
know is always bit boid so the zygote
marks the beginning of the diploid stage
called the sporophyte stage
and so in my picture here the Z stands
for zygote now again I've over
exaggerated the size of the zygote here
just so we can see it in my animation
and zygotes are microscopic but again
the zygote marks the beginning of the
diploid stage and so what happens is
that I I goat will begin to grow or it
will grow upward towards sunlight and so
here we have the sporophyte stage here
we have the young sporophyte stage still
attached physically attached to the
gametophyte stage also called the pro
thalis now eventually the pro thalis the
heart-shaped structure called the pro
thalis eventually will just shrivel up
and die and what will remain is the
sporophyte state and as time goes by you
can see a fiddlehead in this picture as
time goes by the fiddlehead will uncurl
into a friend and that'll restart the
cycle again now we have the the the
spurn has reached the excuse me that the
fern the fern has reached reached its
adult sporophyte stage and once the fern
has reached the adult sporophyte stage
the process simply repeats the fern the
the sorai that produce spores on the
back side of the front will release the
spores into the air and those spores
will land and start this cycle all over
again so if you're trying this at home
pause the video pause the video and try
to put these steps in order I've given
you the first step so pause the video
try to put these steps what comes second
third fourth fifth sixth I'm going to go
over the answer in three two one
so step one spores will land on on the
ground or in soil and once that happens
once that happens a spore will grow into
the heart-shaped structure called the
pro thallus remember that the pro
phallus is the beginning or excuse me
the pro thallus is the gametophyte stage
of a fern well after the pro thallus
grows what comes
will comes next well what happens is
that sperm will swim through water from
the mail and thrid IAM to the female
archegonium and once that happens the
next step should be fertilization will
occur because when sperm swimming
fertilize the egg and there you go
that's fertilization so what happens
after fertilization occurs
well that zygote that is created will
grow into a diploid sporophyte and the
final step once the diploid sporophyte
begins to grow the final step is the
sporophyte really spores and this
process will repeat all over again so
there you go if you're in my class you
know pause this video and try to answer
these questions perhaps on a separate
sheet of paper and I'd love to check
your answers for accuracy before school
or after school one day so go ahead and
pause the video and try to answer these
questions right here good luck